Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the Monday morning podcast.
Uh,
actually it's a special edition of the Monday morning podcast is what I should
be saying.
Uh,
every once in a while I'm graced with the guest and,
uh,
you know,
so you get an extra episode this week.
All right,
so that's an extra hour in your cubicle that you can actually,
uh,
not want to kill yourself and,
going to get right to it.
My guest this week is somebody I've known I think for about 17 years.
Stinking Jim Florentine.
Jim Florentine.
Yeah,
man,
it's good to see ya.
Yeah,
it's probably been,
I mean,
we didn't,
we never did too many gigs together or anything like that.
We were always,
you know,
you were doing your thing.
I was doing mine
in Jersey and I was,
uh,
the suburbs of Boston,
but I always felt like you guys,
uh,
you Norton Voss,
that whole crew,
even though Voss probably started in the 70s,
but I'm just like,
you guys Kinda had the same thing where you weren't in New York City.
Like we both had to like migrate there.
Um,
and I,
and I feel like when I started coming,
I started coming down in New York with Patrice and like 94,
95 moved there and like 95.
And um,
yeah,
I don't think I saw you when you had the long hair.
I think you had your hair cut by then,
didn't you?
Yeah.
Well 92 93 is when me and Norton try to start hit going in New York City and
just,
you know,
what part of she,
yeah.
And then about 94,
95,
but whenever a Kurt Cobain came out like 93,
late [inaudible] 94 when he died or when he came,
when the,
when,
when did,
uh,
he came out to like 96 though,
right?
No,
he came out in September of [inaudible] 91 and then he died in April 94.
And I only know that because of a,
okay,
my love of metal and metal was over and all of a sudden I thought he was a dose
when I first saw him,
when he was doing like making fun of the tap on Solos and that smells like teen
spirit.
I knew he was making fun of metal and I just was,
I thought the guy was a dick.
I'm one of the few people who had met set because everybody,
see,
I've talked about this in the podcast,
people seem to like when they bring up that nirvana album,
nevermind everybody seems to act like they knew that this,
that there was going to be this total shift in music and you know,
there was something in the air and all that and it was just,
it took,
I didn't get nirvana until after in utero and then I saw him in a,
when they did unplugged and right as I started to like him,
a cart killed himself.
Yeah.
The,
I think it's all going to that album and the beginning of the,
I don't want,
you know where it's weird about that.
It's like everyone thinks that that was the album that changed.
I mean it kind of was,
but it wasn't their music specifically.
It was MTV and radio decided that that metal wasn't cool anymore and then we're
going to stop playing.
You know what?
I haven't really like collectively,
like that is amazing that that album came out.
And the second that came out,
it was like all of a sudden all the bands I was watching weren't on MTV anymore.
I remember even
Donna was bitching,
uh,
she had some fucking catty little interview with Kurt Loder and uh,
he's like,
yeah,
you haven't made a too many videos off of this album.
She goes,
well,
why should I make them?
You guys don't show them any way.
You don't show my videos anymore.
And he and a,
she kind of went right at them and then MTV,
like a bunch of pussies started showing her videos like right after that.
Like I would have been like,
yeah,
well fuck you.
You're old now.
Yeah,
I was a lowly,
but no,
what happened was they,
um,
you know,
and then Pearl Jam came about the same time.
They just saw MTV basically decided what,
what was popular and then,
and then every radio,
as soon as they started playing nirvana and Pearl Jam and it was the hot,
the new video,
every radio program across the country goes,
okay,
that's what we got to play now.
And they just totally discarded the metal.
So it wasn't that happen though.
Like they have like some fucking Bilderberg group of like radio stations.
Like they have like a conference yet year it's,
there's this one guy like you know,
one big program are probably the guy from fucking z 100 in New York,
right.
Whatever that Douche bag was.
And he started going,
well you know what Nirvana is the newer pearl jam and then everybody other radio
station.
What's New York ply in an La,
he's playing this all,
we got to play it and then they just copy.
It's just,
you know,
it's like the TV business one show successful on the try to put 50 more out.
Like,
cause I remember that that was a overnight.
And I know I'm old now so I don't pay attention to like music changing.
But that's the last time I remember,
it was just like,
I thought it was going to be like headbangers ball and fucking,
you'd remember that the top,
uh,
what was that thing that,
that guy to tried to dress like a headbanger but wasn't the guy was from like
fucking Sweden.
I'm that European guy with the blonde hair and I'm Cari.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
no.
Is he not when the race was that one of the original guys know,
he was like the guy to wear a leather jacket.
We had to fluff up like Blonde Farrah Fawcett hair.
Yeah.
That was Adam Carr.
So he used the host,
that top 10 thing,
and I swear to God,
like the top 10 was like eight metal videos.
And like maybe Janet Jackson would slip in or fucking Jody Watley.
They'd be like one RMB thing.
And uh,
and then some like new kids on the block thing or something like that.
And,
and then the rest of it was all fucking guns and roses,
skid row.
And I thought it was going to be like that forever,
obviously.
I mean,
it was a young kid.
I didn't know that music changed.
I thought disco suck,
but I have to bring this up.
I talked to you,
right,
right before we started this thing was how I was trashing a lot of the metal
videos that I saw.
I came home one night,
like a late at night and I put on like VH one and I was astounded at how bad
some of the music was that I listened to.
And some of the videos,
like there was one quiet riot one where they actually sort of wrapped or did
some sort of scratching before their song came on.
I want to say it was about Russia.
I don't know if,
I don't know.
It must have been later one.
I combined shit but I like,
I don't know.
Some people think,
I don't know that I don't like metal.
I like it,
but I don't look at it like,
like with like,
uh,
just you know,
with blinders on.
No,
no.
I mean if you look back at those videos,
cause the VH one classic plays them all time metal mania.
I'll play like four hours.
I'm did a fucking awful Ronnie James Dio,
you know,
I love Ronnie.
He was great dude.
And you
know,
I personally know,
but walking around with a sword and fighting these demons and you know I was
saying come on you,
you're playing him that he's going through the woods and he says,
hey dude,
you met where they will out though when you were a kid you thought they were
sick,
were like,
did you see the new deal video dude,
it's fucking unreal.
Yeah.
And then you know they always,
and then the other like the poisons is always at the hot chick in there to warn.
So always had that.
It's like Holy Shit.
Do you see it on hot man?
Is She fucking hot?
You look back six,
she's not that hot.
No,
no they will all they will often.
It's funny cause we're going to have a Nana,
Nancy,
Nancy and Ann Wilson from hard on our show and a couple of days and me and my
friend Eddie,
we're talking to how we used to jerk off to Nancy Wilson cause she had the big
tits and she had to cleavage,
you know,
never is at the redhead.
Yeah,
yeah.
Just anyone.
Yeah.
They always had the tits out.
You know,
they had to in the eighties and I was like that was,
that's what I jerked off to an 87 88 do
you remember when the other one got real fat and they tried to shoot around it
by doing like an extreme closeup of her face?
Yeah.
And they tried everything that they could,
she went,
she was sort of like the original like fat chick from like Wilson Phillips.
Yeah,
yeah.
That she had like the,
I don't like when people get fat and they complain about this business and the
pressure to stay in shape.
It's like you want to be on a stage and eat whatever you want and it doesn't
work that way.
You'll have to come into this business of fat.
Fuck.
Like if you come in that way like,
hey,
it's the fat fuck,
then you're,
you're all good,
but you can't become fat in this business.
You're going to,
you know,
you're going to get trashed.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I mean,
yeah,
she was,
she was hot in the 70s and she will,
she definitely put it on.
I was,
I was reading an article on them.
They were saying how the record company was so afraid to tell her just to lose
weight that she was the record company,
you know,
brought the band in without her and said please talk to her because we don't
want to want to piss her off,
but she has to lose weight.
Right.
And the band went to,
when she got so fucking pissed,
she left the record company at the time,
I think it was capitol,
she like fuck them.
And she was wearing like,
these were all like that leather and stuff.
It's not a good thing.
There's been a couple people who got fed.
George Thorogood got fat.
Yeah.
I still wore those,
those snake skin leather pants and went to some fucking blues festival and he
was there and he came up with these fucking things.
Dude,
he looked like he just had a kid.
It was,
it was awful.
And it was like one of those things where it's like,
dude,
you got to do something where a button down and some jeans and hit the fucking
treadmill.
It's just one of those,
if you like,
in this business.
Absolutely.
You can't,
you can't,
um,
you know,
losing your hair or anything,
like that.
So I still have mine and I'm just saying,
fuck it.
I'm just letting it go.
Yeah.
It started,
I'm starting to go in the back and I'm just like,
uh,
I can't,
what am I gonna do?
I'm a scalp the back of my head and then have that shit put in the front.
I just,
I,
this is why I look at it,
you know,
if I was going to be the next Brad Pitt,
it would have happened by now.
I'm fucking,
you know,
it's like I'm 44 years old.
What am I gonna fucking be some 50 year old sex symbol.
You know,
I'd be the just the,
uh,
I,
you know,
dude,
I do a podcast.
I told jokes I'm,
I'm good.
I can write,
I can make my fucking rent.
I don't need to go there and get my fucking face yanked back and have some pubes
taken from fucking my Dick.
And he stuck on my head.
I mean then the,
no matter what,
this business is going to be finished with me at some point.
So I've kind of made a rule that I am going to try to look like a fucking human
being at the end of this.
Um,
you know,
unless,
uh,
unless they so get like the facelift down.
If they get it down where you actually can still look like a human being.
Like I've been talking lately on stage.
You have you seen that,
that synergenic so whatever it is,
you know,
like those guys,
I look that shit up like those old guys who were shredded.
It's fucking,
they are on HGH.
That's what I thought it was.
Yeah.
There are,
there are their on fucking,
that's why that guy has that tone.
Like he wants to fight his kids in better shape.
My kids,
he feels like he's getting ready to snap.
So like don't they say that that's like cancer causing like that the,
the HGH.
So like those guys,
that's this first wave of old guys.
They're probably gonna fucking something bad's going to happen in four to five
years and then they'll use them as Guinea pigs.
So I figured by the time we get there,
it's like Roy,
it's now like back when we were kids roids you know the shrinking of balls up,
you got fucking titties,
it was horrible and then you fucking died and now,
but now they got that,
that synthetic stuff,
they got the clear they get,
they just keep making it better.
So real quick,
if they,
if they come up with a fucking pill for a full head of hair or you know anything
or if it just feels like your head's on fire for a minute,
I would do it.
But like as far as like scalping the back of my head,
there's no fucking way doing that.
Yeah.
I mean,
yeah,
I'm on the fence about that too.
I mean,
yeah,
I mean there's never been a sex symbol at all of a sudden that 44 now,
even George Clooney up made it like 32 or 33 and that was like late.
He was all he was,
he was around for 10 years doing a little bit parts and all of a sudden they got
er or whatever,
and then he became a sexist.
And plus the advantage of kind of being a mess is no one really pays attention
to your aging as much as like,
like if you're in that people magazine,
50 most beautiful people.
People always say the funny shit that,
oh my God,
you see so and so what happened
her,
what happened to him?
It's like,
dude,
what the fuck happened to you?
You're like,
you think you're like,
you know,
under glass not aging.
So yeah,
you're right.
You're right.
I just,
I try to keep it as low maintenance as possible.
Jeans and a tee shirt and fucking whatever,
and I'm brushing my hair and I'll fucking do anything I don't want makeup on
when I go on TV.
I don't know.
I don't want to know.
We had that God seriously I go to,
I don't,
you know what's funny?
I like how we're acting like being a sex symbol is actually an option.
Yeah,
I know.
Like where to go going,
no,
we don't want that.
If we just took care of ourselves a little better.
Well speaking of book will look,
when I was late eighties early nineties when I had long hair,
I took like Bon Jovi's,
whatever style he had or David Coverdale from Whitesnake and I got a lot of
fucking ass.
So I was almost considered a sex symbol back then even though I wasn't,
but you can be a local sex symbol.
I was in Pennsylvania was a fucking 12 on a scale of one to 10 because they were
still five years behind the hall.
Like,
Hey,
you know,
long hair thing.
So I would do all these gigs out in Pennsylvania.
Just fucking clean up.
That's hilarious.
Do you ever go back there?
Like,
is that like your Germany,
like David Hasselhoff and you ever just go back to Pennsylvania and do like a
book signing or something?
But no,
because once I cut my hair to cut me off,
they no longer liked boys over.
They were mad.
They'll just like,
remember when Metallica cut their hair all the half their fans were pissed.
They fucking cut their hair.
What Felicity?
Yeah.
Who Cares?
Oh,
sort of desks going to change your music.
So when I,
yeah,
they turned it on,
made Pennsylvania too.
Before all my listeners trashed me for knowing the Felicity thing.
I took an acting class with a girl who was on the show.
It was some show called Felicity and every guy like 14 year old boy loved this
girl Felicity.
And then she,
she got her,
uh,
you know,
I'm going to play softball now.
Haircut and the whole fucking show tanked.
And this actress was a little bit older,
so she was,
she came in just bitch and one day because she finally had a fucking regular gig
or something like that.
She wasn't like one of the main people.
Uh,
but you know,
she was on like free,
full fucking episodes of season and this chick cut her hair and like a hundred
people lost their jobs.
Well,
yeah.
So that's how I know what people see.
I could see that.
I remember when Cheryl,
I always start show pro was hot.
I always heard something.
She's on that memo when she came out with that fucking soccer mom hair do for
like a year,
not all off it.
It was really short.
It fuck is you look now
do that.
You can't,
as a woman,
if you come into the business fuckable hot or whatever,
you have to look that way.
The whole,
it's the same thing.
It's the same thing like,
uh,
um,
even as a guy,
as a guy,
if you're coming in and you know,
you're all shredded and you have abs in that type of Shit,
you got it.
You have to,
you can't get fat,
you know what I mean?
Unless you,
I guess you pulling some,
uh,
trying to win an Oscar,
but you can,
but you then have to go back and lose the fuck away.
Absolutely.
That's the thing too.
So if I look like fucking Ron Howard,
you know,
it's,
I've basically,
I realized now that I'm losing my hair,
that I'm going to look like him my whole fucking life,
which is really disappointing.
Um,
that,
you know,
there's no,
uh,
you know,
there's no fucking problem,
but you're,
you're 44.
I mean,
you'll,
you know,
one,
do you think it might,
the career might start slowing down.
Do you think you got to at least 50,
50?
I think it would say what you think it's going to start,
um,
doing what I'm doing right.
If I just do it,
if I make money off my podcast and I make,
and I just keep putting out specials every couple of years,
I'm fucking good.
But my free time is priceless.
Like,
uh,
you know,
you get into this fucking business and they start going,
I want,
you know,
like you just think that you want a TV show and then I know you get kind of
close to it and uh,
I mean,
I don't know like you'll show if I was going to do one,
I like to show like,
Yo is that metal show where it's like it's that's taped and pretty much real
time,
right?
Maybe a couple of pickups or whatever.
And in real time for people not in show business he ever,
it's just basically,
you know,
30 minutes show is shot in like 30 minutes and maybe if there's a couple of
flubs if you said the name of the Amalgam wrong,
you might have to go back and rerecord that.
But like,
uh,
those one hour one cameras,
those are,
that's 12 hours a day.
Like five,
six days,
I think it was at five days a week.
They shoot,
they shoot an episode every four days and they start the next one Friday and you
just keep going.
I Dunno,
I guess it's like three months of your life,
right.
I'm to,
uh,
I,
I would rather just go slug it out in a strip mall and just make money that way
and then just come back here and then fucking play guitar or fuck around.
Absolutely.
Men.
Um,
I love taking time off.
You know,
you got to do it.
Absolutely.
Just,
you know,
cause I was always like,
even I'd work on holidays,
I'd feel like if I didn't get onstage in two days,
I'm like,
what am I doing man?
Fuck,
I ain't gotta be Rusty Shit.
I'm like,
what am I,
what am I doing my career?
Everybody's passing me by and now I'm like,
gives a shit.
Yeah.
No.
Now you've got to like when you guys tape,
like you were out here right now in Los Angeles to tape.
Uh,
like how,
how many of that meant to do what we're doing six episodes.
This we already taped to a few months ago,
whatever they're going to put them.
But yeah,
we take two episodes in a day.
We take from three to seven.
We knocked out two,
two hour episodes and four hours basically were like an hour break in between.
So week.
That's awesome.
Yeah,
we just pop them out and I noticed shit.
You know what I mean?
It's not like I got to study it.
We got guys from iron maiden and shit coming on,
which I've been fans for years.
Like I'm just interviewed one of my idols and does it,
you know,
a camera on which is awesome.
Jesus Christ.
It's not too much research you like you've quietly created,
you created the cocreator on this show that no,
but no,
I mean I pitched it with uh,
you know,
my buddy Eddie trunk,
he's a Dj in New York and he's been on for awhile and worked at record labels
and stuff.
We became friends.
I go on his radio show and we just,
you know,
debate metal and he goes,
I'm going to try to get this as a TV show.
I'm going to be,
that guy is on like a whole other level.
Like he has to be the biggest metal fan ever.
That guy,
like I like he takes it all,
like really like seriously.
Like,
I feel like if I could get into a debate with him and he could actually convince
me that kiss is just as relevant as the Beatles.
Oh yeah.
Hey,
can I get a little like I am seeing,
I mean I can sit there like I love ACDC,
right?
Uh,
but I mean they're not on the same level as the Beatles.
They just not,
you know what I mean?
Like it's,
they're just not,
no,
no.
I love those guys.
I'm not trying to,
no,
I luck they right bands or anything and I love those guys to death by the way.
I thought that was hilarious.
The way they describe your,
uh,
your show,
at least on Wikipedia and they said,
uh,
that that metal show is the,
the tonight show for ACDC fans.
That's the greatest phrase after who came up with that,
I know someone in a review,
someone that came there,
show him,
reviewed it or something,
cause they want the VH one mom to say it's,
it's,
uh,
it's a cross between a view headbangers ball and the veal.
I'm like,
get that fucking nobody.
I go,
no one that likes hard rock or metal watches the view once,
not don't say that tickle knowledge.
It's successful show when they're like,
and they wanted me to set that and interviews and I would never say it and like
they were getting really pissed.
Like he's got tell them to say it's car.
I go,
I'm never saying that.
What is wrong with them?
Just them in general.
See that's right.
When I hear stories like that,
I just like,
how do you just not go?
That is the dumbest fucking idea.
[inaudible] you know what I,
I just feel like sometimes they just have to say something to justify the fact
that they have a desk.
Because if they,
if there's,
they just want to be like,
oh it's,
it's uh,
headbangers ball meets the view.
I came up with that,
that was my contribution to that show and now I want to go create something
else.
I guess that's how they go up.
I'm really not trying to sound like a bitter asshole,
but I am here.
You have to be,
cause it's like,
come on,
we know.
Like no,
I that fan base,
when I go to an Oz fest I can go up to 20,000 people.
Do you watch the view and the fucking about 19,000 would punch me in the face.
Yeah we're going to ask it.
I'm not.
No one would say yes.
So why are we going?
It's a cross between a headbanger as well and the view it as soon as the guy,
if I saw that,
cause I was telling my golf,
I saw that,
I call the view,
I'm not watching that.
And you know what their thought is,
their thought is well this is a very male demographic.
We got to get the females in there.
So then they throw in the view and just they can't,
you know what it is.
They can never make enough fucking money.
They just never make an enough,
they always have to do it and then they got to add some extra fucking thing and
then when it nose dives,
then they'd put it on you and then you would have to bear that cross once you on
that show.
That was like the view.
But you had Ozzie on it and he'd be like,
that wasn't the idea of,
you know,
the other person gets to just skate away.
I know I've been lucky because um,
you know,
to producer gets it and you know,
we fought for,
what would they real?
I think originally they want it to be like a rock of ages type thing.
The goof on the eighties metal.
They wanted us to basically dressed in spandex and put wigs on and you know,
go that stuff.
And we're like,
absolutely not.
We're three fucking guys would know energy.
We're not physical.
We just sit there and we'll talk heavy metal.
But I don't,
we don't make anything bigger.
I'm not,
we're not flashy.
We don't throw kicks.
I got to admit,
I've been real jealous watching some of the people you've gotten to talk to.
Like just knowing you have iron maiden.
Iron maiden is one of my big,
like I fucked up that I didn't go see them.
I could have seen them on the power slave tour.
I forget what it was.
My Dad was pissed at me as something I,
I fucked up like two weekends before and somebody had another ticket and it was
like,
you know,
I was young enough where I still had to ask permission.
It's still living at home like 16,
17.
And I was just like,
uh,
yeah,
I got to let the old man cool off for an I.
I can't make that one.
And uh,
I actually think my friends didn't even make it to the show.
They got so hammered.
My friends were idiots.
But,
uh,
that's one of the big ones.
And you,
I saw one time I was flipping through and I saw,
uh,
you had Jason Bonham on and uh,
you know,
I'm John Bonham freak and I met him one time at Guitar Center in somewhere in
Florida.
I Dunno why he was in there.
He was living down in,
um,
uh,
Fort Lauderdale coral springs for a while.
You think he still lives down there,
Jason.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
Well I ran into him and he was cool as hell.
He liked comedy and I got this like,
you know,
cell phone pictures back then was like a flip camera and they usually awful.
Somehow it was fucking great.
It was just this awesome picture of me and Jason Bonham.
And then I left the fucking cell phone in the Goddamn cab on the way to the
airport and I had never sent it to me.
Oh,
uh,
sent it,
emailed it to myself or anything.
So I was flipping through the fucking channels.
Dude,
I'm such a jump on them like freak that when like,
like when I shook Jason's hand,
like I was thinking like he shook his dad's hand at some point he had to,
if you know,
like you walk around going,
Hey dad,
but it just like,
I literally felt like a,
I dunno,
I was like the biggest fan boy ever.
So when I saw that you had them on the show him on the show as it's like Jesus
Christ,
I mean,
I would,
I,
that guy would have like had to call security if I actually got to sit down and
ask them.
And it would be like 50 million questions about his dad,
but she's probably sick of answering.
Um,
I think he,
um,
you know,
he doesn't mind that though.
He went out and does it holds up one thing.
And supposedly I heard from a reliable source,
there's going to be something going on with Zeplin at the end of the year.
Oh,
is that right?
Yeah,
I don't,
the guy wouldn't say what he's like a famous photographer was really close with
Jimmy page.
Well,
I thought,
I thought Jason Played Great,
uh,
during that last reunion that they did for the head,
the head of Atlantic records when he died.
Yeah.
And what I loved was,
uh,
he just,
he,
he was doing like an amalgam of like studio and live shitty heard his dad do.
Plus he had,
he had a lot of him in it.
Like I thought that he wasn't,
I mean,
that's got to be terrifying because like Zeplin fans and like drummers,
like,
um,
I hate,
like,
I look at like,
there's a lot of people do like drunk crop covers on youtube and they'll do a
drum cover of like a fucking,
you know,
some Zeppelin song and somebody will kill it and someone will be like,
good job.
But there's only one John Bond him.
It's like everybody knows that this guy doesn't think he's fucking John Bonham.
He just loves the guy.
And,
and it inspired him to learn how to play drums and learn how to place.
I've even seen it,
I'm like,
Jason,
Jason's Barnum Hall,
have like,
you know,
him playing drums and he's fucking killing it.
And some would be like,
you know,
yeah,
but he's nowhere near his dad and it's like nobody is right.
And he doesn't have a tee shirt saying,
I'm really near to my dad when it comes to drums.
It's just so fucking annoying.
Um,
and I don't even know why I read the comments.
I just,
I think I just read them just to see that.
Just to get mad though.
Of course.
If John was still around and Jason took Jay,
John Goes,
I'm at a Zepplin and they hired Jason to play drums.
Then you'd go,
hey,
you know you need his dad back.
There is no right.
No John,
but he's not around.
What are you going to do?
So fucking just let Jason [inaudible] Jason.
Right.
Which is why I don't
mine.
When people trash Wolfgang van Halen.
I want Michael Anthony back there.
It's fucking annoying.
They finally got David Lee Roth back in.
Just
get Michael Anthony back in there.
You can never,
he can,
they get,
that will never happen.
How does Eddie throw his son out of the band?
Oh yeah.
You know what I mean?
That's the problem.
And Alex's Day uncle,
he has to leave.
He's got to throw his son thing has to leave.
You know,
Michael's don't want a shell.
Michael and Sam are doing our show this week.
Oh,
where were they going to be at work?
They're taping our show.
Oh,
I think is that,
uh,
this week?
Yeah.
I'll do you want to come out?
If you're around,
you want to come in a tape and I miss everything.
When is it?
Like why?
I think it was Wednesday.
Wednesday,
of course.
Okay,
so it's time for a little advertising.
Um,
all right,
people stamps.com.
Here we go.
There are too many what ifs.
When you go to the post office,
what if there's traffic or what if you can't find parking?
Oh,
what if there's some smelly sob holding the door?
Mommy,
I don't want to go in there.
He's smelly.
I don't care,
Judy.
Things get smelly in life.
You need to push past this.
I married your father.
This is our situation.
Get in there and get the stamps right.
No one wants to go through that.
What if it's closed when you get there?
What if you're too dumb to realize the sun went down and you don't realize that
they're not in the post office anymore?
You understand here there's a lot of what ifs with their limited hours.
You never know.
Avoid all that hassle.
Just use stamps.com what's that bill?
What is stamps.com?
Well,
I'll tell you,
you son of a gun,
a stamps.com is basically bringing the post office into your home,
your apartment,
your flat,
your duplex,
um,
your tented city with stamps.com.
Anything you can,
anything you can do with the post office,
you can now do from the convenience of your own desk.
I've done it.
It's awesome.
You can buy and print official US postage using your own computer and printer.
It's great.
You feel like the king of the world,
uh,
get exact postage for any letter or package whenever you need it,
right?
24,
seven,
unlike the post office,
stamps.com never closes.
Okay.
And you don't have to look at somebody's stupid face when you walk up there.
You know when they put that little thing,
sorry,
this window's closed and you want to beat him with that little side.
Um,
anyways,
I actually use stamps.com.
That's how I send out all of my DVDs.
I put on a little almond,
a mailroom hat,
and I weigh my DVDs and I send them off to a strip mall near you so I can then
go out.
Dance like a monkey and hopefully whore myself out after the shell and sell the
DVDs.
But that's another sad story.
Back to the,
uh,
the special offer here right now.
Use My last name bur bur are for this special offer.
It's a no risk trial plus on $110 bonus offer includes a digital scale to weigh
your letters and packages up to $55 free postage.
All right,
don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the radio microphone at the top of the homepage and type in borough B,
u,
r.
R,
that's stamps.com enter burr and bring the post office into your world.
Stop going into their world.
All right.
It's like the end of one of those nerdy movies.
When you finally find a little thing.
Did I just mess it up at the end there?
All right,
whatever stamps.com do it.
If you want to something for you,
he voiced everybody.
Would you like to have a,
would you like to have your cell phone ring,
but have people not know what your real number is?
You know,
wouldn't you like to get like have a cell phone,
right?
And only your friends and family knew the real number to it.
And then you could come up with these virtual phone numbers that people could
dial that but weren't really your phone number,
but your cell phone would still ring.
Would you be into that?
Would you be into a service like he voice that would allow you to do that and
off these,
these virtual phone numbers,
you could actually a,
you could do conference calling on your own new business and on the conference
call a feature,
we could have actually up to 95 people for each extension.
It's incredible.
It's basically,
it's a business phone number that will,
that will ring on your cell phone.
Okay.
Without anybody knowing your personal one,
which gives you the option of knowing whether it's a business one or a personal
one at night answering it and whatever.
It's absolutely perfect.
It's an amazing thing.
Um,
they offer an entire service where you can a toll free local managing of
outgoing calls.
This is all,
all the,
uh,
this is all the,
the,
what are the options came to think this week.
Uh,
mobility all calls forwarded to a number slash people don't have to know your,
uh,
your personal phone number,
virtual numbers.
So long as you have a real number you can give out fake numbers but it rings on
your own number.
And if you don't pick up on your business,
uh,
your,
your new virtual phone number,
they actually have professional accents,
a professional voice,
actors to give you any,
any sort of like,
like an outgoing message.
Like if you want to give the illusion that you,
your business is bigger than it is and you have a bunch of employees,
one of the options that they have is that you can actually have,
like I personally,
I would pick some sexy female voice with like a British accent.
Just gives your business credibility.
You know,
they'll send you emails with the text transcription of the voicemail or not.
The option is totally yours.
Uh,
it's a great way to basically have all these different business lines without
having to drill a bunch of holes in the wall and your house,
you know,
you've got [inaudible] welcome to you.
A which,
which it's IRS or whatever.
I'm doing a bad accident.
You know what I'm saying?
You can start the whole frigging thing.
So it's email,
uh,
he voice check it out today.
Do I have a website here?
Where the hell is this?
Uh,
hang on one second.
Let me get this website.
Yeah,
it's easy.
voice.com.
There you go,
Bill.
He a genius.
Um,
once again,
he voices your mobile phone at work.
It's perfect for business,
a businessperson on the move.
Uh,
like myself,
I'm actually going to get one of these phone numbers just because when I
traveled from Club to club and all these,
uh,
different radio stations,
like my,
my phone number gets out there and,
and I,
I get weird phone calls sometimes.
You know,
I rented a car in Chicago like Avis,
like three months ago,
and then out of nowhere I got it.
I had to write down my fucking cell phone number.
And uh,
the guy worked at Eva's called me up.
I'll actually sent me a text.
Hey,
saw you stand up the other day.
Really funny.
I'm the guy who rented you the car at Avis,
which is beyond creepy and I'm a dude so I can only imagine how that would make
a female.
So it gives you a great,
like a privacy options while you still exist in the business world.
Uh,
features eve voice offers includes call forwarding,
call routing,
toll free 800 numbers,
auto attendant,
um,
advanced voicemail,
voicemail detects or voicemail the email,
however the hell you want to do it.
A click on the voice banner on billboard.com on the podcast page or go to www
dot [inaudible] dot com slash bill burr to get your exclusive six month free
trial,
six month free trial evil.
Yeah,
he voice your mobile phone at work.
Um,
that's one of those ideas where I'm just like,
that right there is why I'm not a billionaire because I just look at that.
Like that idea was just out there and uh,
I just did nothing.
Why didn't I jump on that?
Like Youtube,
that's one of those ideas.
Um,
anyways,
but now I'm telling you about them,
so you gotta check them out.
These guys are great.
All right.
Um,
cause I've actually done half the shit that they do here and I paid a fucking
lawyer to do it.
It costs me a zillion dollars.
All right?
If you basically,
are you sitting in a cubicle right now?
Are you wondering why you're making somebody else's dream come true while you're
working towards that?
When you actually have an idea for a business,
you know,
well,
and you sit and they go,
I'd love to get myself incorporated to start my business,
but it's going to cost a fortune.
Well,
at legal zoom.com if you've been waiting for the perfect time to start your
dream business,
uh,
right now's the time to do it.
You can incorporate your business or form an llc@legalzoom.com starting at just
99 bucks.
It costs me like 1500,
something like that.
700 1500,
I can't remember.
It was a lot of money.
They'll do it for 99 bucks.
And if you have a family,
um,
and you need to make sure that they're protected,
legal zoom also will help you,
uh,
make out your last will and testament for just 69 bucks.
That's something that I have to do.
All right.
I have to make up my last will and testament,
which is really a scary thing for me to do.
You know,
cause you're actually dealing with your own mortality.
And considering I just had a dream like I did last night,
it freaks me out,
but I got to tell you if I'm going to do it,
I'm doing it for 69 bucks.
Um,
in the past 12 years,
over 2 million Americans have used legal zoom for Llcs,
wills,
trust,
trademarks,
and more.
This is basically,
look,
if you're trying to start a business or if you need a will to protect your,
this is the place to go.
Uh,
you're gonna save hundreds,
even thousands of dollars versus going the traditional route.
And I know what you think of.
Well,
what if I get bogged down?
What have,
what have,
I can't figure it out.
They even have an attorney to help you if you need,
uh,
if you need help.
Basically they have attorneys that you can call in that type of stuff.
All right.
Mandatory close.
Sorry.
It was supposed to.
There is the mandatory,
close everybody to this ad.
Start Your Business and protect your family today@legalzoom.com.
You can also get a special discount from listening to this podcast.
Make sure you enter bur you are in the referral box and check out,
uh,
at checkout for more savings.
Legal Zoom is not a law firm and self help services are provided at your
direction.
All right?
So that's the deal there.
It is.
You want to start your business.
You want to be incorporated.
That is the cheapest,
most efficient way to do it.
Uh,
I wish they were around back when I got incorporated.
Could have saved myself hundreds of dollars.
So they got legal zoom,
I fucking miss everything.
And then we got Steve Harris taping that same day too from me.
Of course you do.
It's why wouldn't you,
why wouldn't you?
And then they'll raffling off a,
uh,
John Bonam drum kit that you had paid and John Paul Jones and coming in on
Thursday.
Can you make that,
ah,
you know,
he's got some insane stories but isn't an in a,
is an in a metal band?
Is Steve Gorman from a,
the Black Crows?
I did his podcast.
If you're ever,
I don't know if you know,
you were telling me about,
oh my God,
he's got some great,
and I'm not going to tell any of them.
I'll tell them,
see when we're off,
just to give you a,
just to some of the stories,
but I mean,
I don't know what he wants out there.
Plus he lived them so he tell him better.
But um,
I didn't,
hell that I get to know him.
I think I do on this podcast is I got to know him and in the black Crowes came
and they were playing the palladium one night,
did some epic like three hour show,
like first half was acoustic,
then they came out to the electric stuff was incredible.
And,
um,
he's one of those just really just,
you know,
Ben through it and back and back again,
so just totally down to earth.
Totally cool guy,
man.
He would be great.
I mean,
I don't know if black crows or to a rolling stone,
they would fit in.
Yeah.
Well,
I'll tell you,
that guy would be a fucking amazing guests if he told half the story.
So just one or two of them,
they just really like a,
you know,
it's,
what it is,
is a comedian.
We have a bunch of stories,
but so much of it is solo shit.
And as much as you might not get along with another comedian,
um,
you don't have to go out on the road with them.
And it's just that thing of like,
you know,
I've done a couple of comedy tours and it's just like,
there's always,
there's the late guy,
there's the fucking loud guy,
there's the dude to snoring.
You know,
there's always,
there's always in,
you have to learn how to get along with those people.
I don't know how the fuck these bands do it.
I don't either.
Man being on a tour bus for frigging six months at a time.
No.
And bunks and they all got that fucking story too.
Like the,
the
tour ends,
like they just,
they just all leave in different cars by then and they don't talk to each other
for like fucking eight months.
Yeah.
It's unreal.
I mean,
I don't know.
Uh,
I think that's how I would have been with my friends if I was in my early
twenties when you don't recognize like,
Hey,
shit's getting out of control with everybody's relationships.
We need to have a sit down here and you just let it get to that point with a
level of resentment is so high.
You don't even give a fuck that you're playing arenas.
You're going to walk away from that.
You can't get along with the Bass player.
Does that even,
it doesn't even make sense.
Right?
They,
um,
yeah.
Speaking of which,
I will get an Aerosmith coming on the show this week.
Of course you do.
So of course.
Who else do you got that I'm not going to be able to come into?
I finally have a fucking hookup in this God damn.
Well actually,
whilst they're going to take on a Sunday,
not Joe,
Joe and Steve and it's the other three,
Brad,
Tom Hamilton and Joey Kramer.
That's even cooler though.
I know we want to set the unsung heroes of Aerosmith.
Yeah,
that's even cooler is I don't want to talk to Steven Tyler about fucking
American idol.
I don't give a shit.
You know what I mean?
He said he's done though.
Yeah,
I know he has done but I'm just saying I didn't want to revisit that or any of
that crap.
So we've got these other guys coming on,
but there was a point where they weren't that they'll step bands always been
fighting for years.
There was a point that didn't even apply for two years and they were doing a gig
over and like the buy and they were getting like $5 million to headline this big
rock festival and they had to do to Gig.
They weren't going to cancel it.
They didn't talk to Tyler for two years that Tyler didn't eat.
They didn't even talk to him before he walked on the stage.
He didn't,
wouldn't even rehearse with them.
you know,
the four to one big show,
they didn't like the first time they saw him in two years is when he walked out.
When they started,
when they opened up,
we're like sweet emotion when he hit the microphone.
That was the first time they even saw him.
That's how much they hated when Neely,
yeah,
he would,
he didn't fly that.
So then when they did the show was he's still putting his arm around Jackie.
He just went up there like nothing happened.
But then you saw like six months later I had another gig and fucking Joe knocked
them off the stage.
They had a plot day at a whole lot stage going out to the crowd,
like a little at the end and Joe frigging nudged him and he went flying into the
crowd and he broke his,
uh,
like his arm or something like that.
He cancel a tour and Joe's like,
I do what?
I tell them all the time,
but you could see he did it on purpose like,
dude,
fuck you man.
You sit home for two years.
That would happened.
I don't know cause he was a cop.
Just think as a us as a comic,
we have to deal off.
I thought he fell off the stage and then he got mad because nobody in the band
ran over to see what he was.
Well,
if you watched a youtube video,
Joe nudges him and he goes,
I do what I do.
Well you'll do right all the time to each other.
But he thought he was right on the edge.
You could see he fucking hit it on purpose,
but not yet.
Just imagine what that's like sports right there.
I know.
Is that he,
was he going through their head that he hit him with the shoulder?
Is that an El bus game?
A little fuck away from me.
He can't get mad at the other guys didn't come to see the shows.
Got to keep going.
They just kept playing,
hoping he was going to crawl back up.
Wow.
But just imagine as a comic,
like say you know,
there's three or four of us touring together.
Right.
And then all of a sudden one guy's being an asshole and doesn't want to do to
tour six months from now and we've got to sit home for two years and can't play
right.
That will drive it.
I,
that would drive me out of my mind.
And then he goes on and does like a reality show.
Yeah.
I mean,
Joe Perry,
Justin,
just join another band.
Go Fuck.
I gotta get up on stage.
They sit home and do nothing.
I saw Joe Perry project went out.
I saw them at the,
uh,
the house of Blues.
Oh yeah.
It was cool.
And then like,
you know,
when,
when they come to la,
all the musicians,
so many of them out here,
it's like New York.
So who came out like slash came out and a couple other guys like slashes to
shit.
He came out and jammed with the opening band.
Like he doesn't get,
he just doesn't care.
He just wants to play.
It was speaking of torture.
I mean it must've been tortured for him having a wait all those years for axel
before he just finally said,
fuck it,
I'm going to do my own thing.
You know?
Well that's the thing that people always ask if we going to do,
you know,
vaccines or whatever.
Get the original band back together first of all and not broke.
So that's not gonna happen.
They only do it when that broke axle band,
you know,
guns is huge still.
And over in Europe they put forth in front of like 30,000 people.
So he's got money slash it makes money.
All doffs a frigging financial whiz.
He's fucking get invited.
He owns like half a Starbucks.
He's good.
And you know,
Steven did drummers,
the only one that's,
you know,
he still has some money but he could,
he could use it.
Izzy who wrote most of the songs is like a fucking gypsy and just lives in a
frigging like RV and just travels across the country.
So he doesn't need any money.
Wa what band is he?
And he was selling the rhythm guitar player and guns and roses.
Yeah.
Izzy in the Juju hounds was his,
it's all up there.
You Solo records to so they don't need the money.
But um,
slash even said,
he goes,
look,
I'm in my fucking forties now.
He goes,
and if we ever got back together,
the original band and the,
the opening band got off stage at nine o'clock and axle didn't want to go on to
1130 way to make those fans wait.
He goes,
I'd walk out the fucking door on the bus and I go,
I'd be in my bed by fucking 10 o'clock cause I would never put up with that.
I'm not going to sit,
I'm not fucking sitting around for two and a half hours.
See that seems to be a problem is that they,
when I read slash his autobiography,
you know the few books that I've read,
if you ever saw like a list of the books that I read,
it be fucking hilarious.
He's like a couple of classics count of Monte Cristo,
right,
prince in the popper or some shit.
And then the rest is just all of core.
I've,
Tommy land is one of my favorite books.
I mean hammer of the gods.
I remember reading that thinking that they were the really sold their soul to
the devil.
Right.
Other than,
yeah,
just some bad shit happens in life sometimes.
But uh,
I I remember reading the slash phone just go in like why and they,
there's a point in the book where Matt Sorum finally just goes down and knocks
on his dressing room drawers or is his,
uh,
trailer is like,
get the fuck out here.
The fuck are we doing?
Like it just seemed like everyone was just sort of appeasing every demand that
he had.
I don't know if cause they were doing drugs and stuff and they're like,
as long as I get my little fucking pile of heroin over here,
hey,
take,
take control the name of the band.
I don't give a fuck.
Like all that crazy shit that he did.
Um,
oh,
you actually got like one of the few like sit down interviews with him,
didn't you?
Would Axel.
Yeah.
What was that like?
It was amazing.
He's a good dude,
man.
You know,
he's just,
look,
he's a hermit.
He's frigging private.
He doesn't want any publicity.
You know,
he just sits at home and when he feels like going on tour and he tours and you
know,
he's a maniac.
I like,
you know,
just that he,
he asked everything has to be 100% perfect for him to go on stage from the,
put a song out.
That's why it took him so long.
But he's a good dude.
Once a perfectionist.
Jimmy's of total perfection.
Perfectionist.
Yeah.
And they just,
and,
but he's got a great sense of humor.
He's just a down to earth dude.
But,
and there's so many rumors about the guy and we talked to him about it.
He goes,
I don't even,
he goes,
what am I going to do?
A dress,
a different room or every fucking five minutes about me know the London press
said like a year ago said that he just,
he kills all the neighbor's dogs.
He,
he'd be backs over him when his truck and then he runs back over and he's like,
what am I going to do?
Am I going to go out and issue?
He goes,
some people think people think I'm this big asshole.
He cause whatever.
I just,
how many rumors do you come up with with that?
That's the next one.
Like alien.
We already got that one.
Aa Battery runs over him again.
Yeah,
he runs them over again.
Jesus.
He's like,
so it goes to just,
there's so much bad shit about me out there.
He goes,
he's not going to,
I'm,
and he addressed all the thing about being late.
He goes,
even as a kid,
my job was right next door and I would still be a half hour late.
I'm always just running late.
I'm an airhead when it comes to that.
But he goes,
I like everything to be perfect.
Whatever I do.
And it just
take [inaudible] your head.
Like,
I don't know where my car keys out,
but when you hear 80,000 people with their,
what the fuck?
Where are you energy or whatever.
They perform to 30,000 people.
I think,
uh,
you know,
I don't know this.
No,
there's gotta be something wrong with you.
Like if you were sitting backstage in an Improv or theater and the opening act
got off and you just sitting back there and you hear the crowd,
like what the fuck?
And you sit there for an hour and a half later,
I'm not ready.
No.
Yeah.
Make them wait another 45 minutes.
Does no way we do that in a million years.
No,
I would be so afraid that that might,
that would be the last time anyone would ever come to see me.
Absolutely.
And even do that.
A respect for the fans.
I would do it out of fear of going back to what the fuck I used to have to do,
you know?
Um,
speaking of that,
how much,
uh,
how much standup do you get to do like,
during the year now with all your projects?
I know like two weekends a month I'm out,
you know,
do what rob stuff.
See You doing it then?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I still,
you know,
do a funny bone,
Improv.
Do you still go down to like the clubs in New York or anything?
I once in awhile I do to sell are killing me man.
I'm like the,
I feel like I'm the only guy.
Like I go down to the comedy store and the Improv out here and like when I think
about all the guys that I started with and all of that,
like I dunno,
like a lot of them,
they just don't come around to the clubs anymore.
Maybe I need more of a home life.
You got a kid now,
right?
Yeah,
I've got a kid so that's tough,
you know,
you know that totally do a seller spot.
A 1210 eight happened and I can get home,
you know,
and it never running late and then I get home at like one 30 or two cause I want
to hang,
you know,
and just be a,
talk and hang out and shit and you know,
catch up with everybody and then you know,
he's up at fucking seven.
Yeah.
You know what mean?
It was amazed at how Norton could,
you know,
once he got the opiate Anthony Gig,
I remember like a few times I sat in for him and I would go out and try and do
stand up that night and I was already wiped out if I had done the show that day
and then try to get up at like five 30 in the morning,
like he's been doing that like what,
10 years?
12 years.
That's ridiculous.
I don't know how he does.
He's a maniac.
Yeah,
during the day.
How does he do?
Yeah,
he said that he takes a nap during the day but still it's like,
you know he kits the early spot,
you know he gets is probably done by like 10 o'clock he said he goes to bed at
like midnight and gets up at five
five and in his brain is that quick.
Like he has one of the quickest minds.
Never.
I,
I've never gone in there and I've seen him just like,
like not on even gym.
Like if he's tired,
his brain always seems like it's like minor down cause he's so fucking miserable
at anything.
Will set them off.
You know what,
I love what he does and I like how he send to that UFC shit.
I like when he has the guys come in and they do the holds.
They'll like choke him and he'd be here.
That fucking noisy made.
Put that on a loop.
I watched that one time when I was on the road just fucking laughing my ass off
for like,
like just killed like a good 10 minutes on the road.
Just dying.
Laughing.
Yeah.
You can get these guys put him in choke holds.
They frigging the,
I was at one time this guy like what did he do?
He took it,
he kicked him with his Shin like a right you right where you get a Charlie
horse.
Right.
And they'll look on Jim's face was so priceless because it was like one of those
pains that were so severe like it,
it was like a pause before it's set in and then he literally looked like
nauseous and I remember Kenny was upset to go nick.
He's like,
fuck,
do I do enough to hit them?
That hawk,
those bolts.
Should we do enough to hit them?
Not Hard,
but it was,
it was worth it.
He's a trooper man.
He really a yes man,
they did.
That guy deserves everything.
He gets it.
I mean that guy would get off a plane on fucking Christmas Day and do three
spots at the seller until what?
The comic strip.
I'm like,
dude,
you could take a day off.
Yeah,
I'll had a family fun.
I got to,
I got spots.
I got to do it.
Yeah.
You remember that shit when we used to go down,
when we used to do the food spots at the cellar and we would do them and then
you'd play,
uh,
everybody would play chess and just shit on each other.
If you weren't playing chess upstairs at the olive tree.
Thank you.
Know.
I love about that.
Thank God nobody was.
Cause I'm so fucking codependent.
If they were all drinkers,
I would have been boozing like every night with them.
Uh,
but thank God they weren't.
So everyone just sat around like,
like Patrice never drank.
Jim doesn't drank.
Probably didn't drink.
Yeah.
None of those guys drank.
And I remember,
uh,
getting into this,
this cycle of going down there and doing like a 12,
12,
30,
you know what's up,
David Tell was always a 12.
So I'd be on after,
I'm like 1245,
1250.
And then you just sit there and you always be like,
I'm going home early tonight.
I'm going home early.
And I seen it was like four in the morning.
You want a times I took the subway home,
you take the six from Astor place.
I take it up when I was living with fucking Bobby and we'd be getting off the
train and the sun was coming up and people were coming out to go to work and uh,
it was so fucking busy.
It was kind of cool.
But then also I always felt like an album,
cause I used to be like a morning person had like a paper route and all that
type of shit.
And,
uh,
then you get in that awful cycle where you'd go to bed at like seven 30 sleep
til like three or four and then you just wake up and do what?
Get breakfast and it was time to go down in the fucking seller again.
Yeah,
that's,
that's a tough,
I,
you know,
I live with Norton for like four years and that's what,
that was his schedule.
I would go to bed.
I like to,
I was never a six o'clock.
I go to two and get up at 10 he was a guy that,
you know,
at seven in the morning,
he'd still be up and then I have to wake him up at like six o'clock.
I go,
dude,
you got spots you've got to sell.
Or at eight o'clock I'd be waking them up at six o'clock.
How long did you live with him?
Like three,
probably three years.
And you guys were,
you guys seem like you'd be able to get along good.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
We got along great and we live right outside the city.
We paid like 300 bucks.
We left.
We had a,
I had a girlfriend at the time,
they live with us,
so it was 900 bucks for Ren.
So we split it three ways,
300 bucks a piece.
Perfect.
We're fucking five minutes away from the Gw or the Lincoln tunnel was beautiful,
is a shit hall.
It was fucking mauled all over the walls and stuff.
We didn't care.
Act 300 bucks.
It's fucking beautiful.
I lived with
Bobby and uh,
we almost killed each other by the end and,
but I actually learned how to let shit go bike.
Bobby has this,
this great thing where he can get past shit.
And I didn't see,
I didn't come from a school where you got past shit.
It's like you did something to me and then we had,
fuck you,
fuck you.
And then the shit was over.
But I learned through him how to be like,
all right dude,
you know,
you don't write somebody off because they spilled orange juice on your fucking
little kitchen TV that you had there,
you know.
Um,
but we lived in,
we lived three people in a Walkthrough,
one bedroom apartment that was a one bedroom and then it was like a sitting
room.
Right.
And they actually use that as like the bedroom.
And then in the living room Bobby had a pullout couch that he slept on.
It was ridiculous.
And they are our roommate.
You anything in particular brought a chick back there?
He always fucking walkthrough like Bobby put like shower curtain up.
It was fucking hilarious.
And the guy always would come fucking any fucking like try and peek in to see
the chicky with Oh yeah.
You know,
not during but like afterwards when you fucking land there.
So one time Bobby fucking,
you know the dude came walking through.
So Bobby was naked and he was underneath the covers.
So what he did when the guy was coming back,
cause when he come back as the way you were laying in the bed and then he'd look
to see,
I don't know,
see her titties or whatever,
Bobby pulled the covers off of himself and was laying there totally naked and
the dude came walking in locked eyes with Bobby and Bobby's just like,
what's up?
I ain't never did it again.
He never did again.
It was fucking,
it was brilliant.
It was fucking brilliant.
It was classic Bobby Kelly,
like,
you know,
I would have sat there for fucking four days trying to figure out how I'm gonna
approach this subject with him.
He just got right to the cloud.
Just show him my junk.
That'll freak them out and I don't have to say anything.
It was fun.
It was fucking perfect.
That's great.
I used
to have a roommate where his dad used to come home and want to look at the girls
that were,
we brought home.
Oh yeah.
He was real creepy,
right?
Yeah.
He would always like,
he fucked one of his son's girlfriend's after they broke up.
Wow.
Yeah.
Was totally a younger guy now.
I mean,
you know,
he was like 20 he was probably like 45 and we were 20 something like that.
And He'd bald duty.
He wasn't good looking at all or anything like that.
Yeah,
so he's old.
So I remember one time like we were,
we only had one bedroom were sharing.
We had these two girls there and I was on the floor one and he was,
the son was in the bed with the other and he comes home and he's peeking in and
he turned the light on.
He looked that,
never forget.
He looked at the bat and he couldn't really see it.
Then he looked in the ground,
he saw this girl and she was fucking fat and this is what I got.
And he's like,
who the fuck's with Orca down there?
I know he said,
Dad said that.
Yeah.
What did the girl do?
She,
I would just like,
Oh dad did tag you get outta here.
And we just put it around them out.
I'll try to,
but he didn't drown out at all because it was,
it was awful.
We were,
I was trying to hold it in cause it was pretty fucking funny.
Who's what,
Orca.
Yeah,
that the,
yeah.
I never had like,
I could never hook up with somebody.
I was,
I,
some of my friends,
they could just hit anything that fucking move just for the numbers I always
had.
They had to be some sort of like some sort of attraction.
Uh,
I,
I remember a couple of times with my friends like,
dude,
what the fuck?
And I was just like,
dude,
she froze and they'd be at least let it blow you.
And I was like,
yeah.
So I tried to do that one time and up hooking up with this girl and she was,
oh,
she just was fucking,
I,
I don't,
you have a couple of the girls,
she's like young,
but she wears like an old person's perfume.
Oh,
the war.
She was fucking 80 hall.
She smelled like she was fucking 80.
And that's all I could remember.
I just remember banging her doggy style with my head turned to the side.
It was horrific.
No,
that's,
that's bad.
Yeah,
I did.
I went through that phase for awhile,
but then it,
I needed,
you know,
it had to be quality,
but there was times where,
because I
quality dude,
I never saw it.
Like there was certain guys I saw,
you know,
they bring girls down to the cellar.
I was never go broke girls down to the cellar.
I never like a,
I never trusted.
Like I just feel you just bringing them down to the lions.
Well yeah.
Yeah I know.
I know
if someone didn't take her they at the very least,
you know,
I would go down there and take a pounding,
some epic fucking pounding.
I remember one night Patrice was getting,
was going after Norton and Norton had some girl there and they got into it a
little bit.
Uh
yeah cause no one doesn't like that.
Like if,
you know,
he says something cause Patrice will say something that a girl or something in
Norton doesn't like to get,
you know,
if he perceives he's getting totally
sense,
which totally makes sense.
But you know Patrice,
once he saw that,
that Jim was annoyed,
it was fucking hilarious.
It was really,
really fun.
Jim Really got mad and that,
you know,
of course the,
they squashed it the next fucking
what portray or did that what?
I brought a girl down.
She said something stupid while you're sitting at the table.
He's trying to be nice and she just said something and I forgot what it was and
Patrice just laid into her and the girls are like,
oh I want to go.
We're going to get an ad of why is he so mean?
Yeah,
first I was bad.
Now that I'm on my couch so he's an asshole.
I don't know.
You know,
I thought he was my friend.
I don't know why he would say it.
Meanwhile I'm like,
that was fucking funny.
You've deserved it.
But I wasn't going to say that.
No.
I would portray some Keith Robinson if they were ever there together.
It just was like,
why would you do that to self?
Like I didn't have the skill to still get laid after parading.
The girl passed those two fucking guys because they were either going to trash
her or they were going to trash me and make me look like an asshole.
Or even where I,
I really took some epic,
epic fucking poundings down there.
I was not good at deck.
It took me,
I was not good at that game,
just sit in their trash people because the way I learned the game was it was
serious.
And you went right for the fucking juggler.
Like Bobby has that a little bit,
um,
which is why we probably almost killed each other when we were living together.
But,
um,
I don't know.
You know what I wanted to talk about here?
How far into the salary?
45 minutes.
By the way,
you're fucking great guest.
Thank God I appreciate them.
You know what I mean?
There's nothing better than when somebody comes over and they can just shoot the
shit.
They're the worst.
You know what,
if somebody comes there,
like I imagine on your show and be like,
yeah,
you had one of the greatest albums of the 80s.
What was that like?
And they were like,
Oh yeah,
that's nice.
Yeah,
it was good.
It was um,
you know,
yeah it was.
There's some other ones that were good too,
but that was,
I know
we always discuss that and like lucky that Guy Eddie Eddie trunk,
that's,
you know,
one of the host.
He's been in the business for 30 years so he knows these guys.
So before he'll go look,
that's disguise a tough interview.
Right?
Same much or you can't get much out of them.
Or this guy just talks,
he'll keep going and going.
So we've got to cut him off so he knows which
then I guess you can't name a name,
but who's been like just the toughest like
you know who is tough to interview but a great guy,
one of the great as Lemmy from Motorhead,
cause he's an old cranky British guy.
Fuck,
I love La.
He's my favorite one.
Anyway,
when he passed,
man,
it's going to be a fucking sad.
I saw that documentary on him.
Crazy and he's just a legend man.
But he's,
he just gives one more to answers and you know,
he needs a few cocktails and I'm the lighten up.
And if we're taking a three in the afternoon,
he's got to have a few jacks and,
um,
and,
but he just cause a lot of one word answers.
He goes,
Nah,
I don't,
I didn't like that Alma had to me.
It was terrible.
And that's his answer.
He's not being a dick,
but that's just the way he is.
So it's tough to get stuff out of him.
Uh,
he,
he makes,
he's a funny dude,
me hope that guy that you can booze at that level still,
dude.
You know what I mean?
66 years old.
Smokes two packs of cigarettes a day.
Marlboro reds drinks a bottle,
at least a bottle of Jack Daniels a day and still does,
you know,
crystal meth from time to time and been doing it first since he was Jimi Hendrix
roadie back in the day.
So he's been doing it since the early seventies.
I watched a documentary on him.
Yeah.
He just decided to try like every kind of bourbon or every kind of scotch.
I don't know what it was.
And he had all the bottles,
like on his window sill on the floor going up a bookcase.
I mean it looked like,
uh,
like if they ever said,
hey bill,
this is all the whiskey.
Uh,
you and your friends drank over the last 25 years.
And with him,
I think he was just knocking them out.
I Dunno dude.
He's,
he's,
he's taught more hardcore to Keith Richards,
like Keith Richards with the drugs and you know,
I read Keith's book.
Okay.
Also.
Yeah,
of course.
Cause that's my library.
He seemed like he said like basically,
you know,
I think he has a drink every now and again.
But like,
since basically from 1980 on,
he's been clean.
But like the publicity publicity that he got when he was doing heroin and
getting arrested and everything,
like he was never able to shake that.
But he talked about like the way he did coke,
he goes,
you don't just sit there and just keep doing it.
And he's like,
you do a bump and then you get on with the party or whatever.
You know what I mean?
You don't get so fucking high,
you got to keep doing it.
He seemed like a really like in control kind of a user anyways.
You know what I mean?
He didn't like,
I mean as a comedian,
my all the reference is always like,
you know,
and then the nuclear holocaust comes,
cockroaches and Keith Richards and the only people he's going to be shooting
heroin into his eye.
And you just,
I just kept hearing that and I thought that that's how the guy was and I guess
he wasn't at all.
Yeah.
I mean he,
I think he had it like a good 15 year run from like 65 to 80 where he was just,
you know,
we drank coke and stuff like that,
but then he stopped.
So he's not really that,
but I mean has been doing it since,
you know,
1970 that's unreal considering also that Betty Ford clinic didn't come around to
like what the mid seventies early eighties early.
Yeah.
So like nobody really knew like that first,
you know,
wave of people,
the Elvis's and them,
you know,
just people not knowing that somebody has a problem and they need like an
intervention.
I mean if you will,
getting high from 65 to 80 and you figured out an 80 that's pretty good.
Yeah,
I think through it.
I,
I got a problem with that shit man.
And like the level that I like to drink.
I'm not an alcoholic,
but like,
you know that stupid joke,
I'm not an alcoholic,
but I drank like one like,
I mean I don't do Lemmy level of drinking,
but like,
um,
I haven't drank in like a month,
just took a month off and uh,
I don't get like that.
Like,
Oh wow,
everything's awesome and,
and it just makes me want an everyday,
it's like I'm adding to the equation of how much I want to drink.
Like after a week it's like I,
I'd love like fucking four beers and then the second week I had,
I'd love a 12 pack and now it's just like I want to drink like Lemmy feel like I
have to drink like that and then realize,
oh,
you can't do that.
Then I stop.
Then you stop.
I go like cold Turkey,
but I'm not like fiending for it.
I just fucking like it.
You know what I mean?
Absolutely.
Man.
I was never one of those to like,
my grandparents always had like a drink at the end that at night,
you know?
I'm like,
Eh.
I'm like as a comic we never did
that.
Were like,
ah,
you would just go to fucking God.
You guys didn't cause I would have if you guys did.
I would have,
but yeah,
I never did it.
Especially it's like I'm,
if I'm on the road or about the fucking Fort Lauderdale for three,
four days,
y'all have some beers after the show,
maybe a couple of shots.
But you know when you're home doing comedy sets in New York,
I'm like,
no,
why don't,
I would never even think about having a beer or anything.
Thank God.
But now as I get older,
I'm like,
yeah,
I have a glass of wine,
have a couple.
But I don't go that far.
I never,
that was never my,
uh,
I never had that problem with the alcohol.
I always just wanted to get a little buzz on just so I can wrap with chicks
cause I had no,
I was shy and stuff.
I had a little buzz on.
I'd fucking have some balls to go up to.
Let's say that that was my whole thing.
That's really why I started drinking.
That's why I never get into drug.
So you'd see my buddy's doing coke on Friday night.
We write and to go out to there and they would do coke and they would just
fucking just spent 300 bucks and just fucking want to talk all night.
I'm like,
let me just have fucking a six pack and let's go to the bar.
It's like a wrap with chicks.
What are you guys doing?
You're not solving anything over there.
Fucking talking about American Indians.
Who gives a fuck.
Do you know,
somebody told me a story about Patrice recently.
I never,
I never heard this one was about,
he was talking to his mom about trying weed.
He tried it a couple of times and was like,
and then,
you know,
tried it,
got high and then just got the munchies and eight and he told his mom,
he was just like,
look,
I'm just going to fucking save the money that I would've spent on weed and just
go buy the food.
Just fucking get right to that.
And it was just such a classic for trees where he was always analyzing and
breaking shit down that he didn't have to go through.
Fucking 20 is like,
dude,
I gotta I have some friends,
you know,
in this business and outside of this business who have been regular users,
like fucking getting a bag of weed every fucking week since we've been like 15.
Right.
Through getting married and having kids.
And,
um,
I mean,
I guess it's all right if it doesn't get in the way of,
uh,
you know,
life.
But,
you know,
I got a couple of guys where it's just,
I dunno it at some point,
like I feel like a fucking [inaudible].
The thing with like booze is you can fool yourself by sitting there drinking
like a,
you know,
if you're sitting like in a parking lot,
shotgunning beers,
it's pretty obvious that,
you know,
you're too old to be doing this,
but you put on a sport coat and he had a whiskey bar.
All of a sudden you feel like this,
this sophistication to what you're doing.
And it's like,
no dude,
you're getting loaded.
You did this outside the Worcester Centrum before fucking Judas priest concert.
You're still doing it.
Yeah,
it's just,
you put in Scotch and a glass now instead of drinking fucking beer out of a can
and the parking lot,
you know,
you're trying to class it up.
Although I never drank wine.
I'm like wines for fucking pussies wine.
I'd see my friend.
What the fuck you drinking?
Why?
Nah,
it's good.
And it's nice and mellow.
I'm like,
oh,
what a fucking numb queer you are.
And now and like the last five years I'm like,
I fucking,
I buy the wine country twice.
I'm like,
this is awesome.
I've always so I hate this bottle.
I hate that.
I like it.
It's a horrific,
terrific
hangover.
But I hate that.
I like it.
Cause to me wine was,
it was something that rich people did all right.
And then it was like the soccer mom thing,
like there's so many soccer moms out there like they were running joke is,
is if it's after four o'clock or after five o'clock,
you don't have a drinking problem if you sit down and have that glass of wine.
But from what I've heard,
you know,
having kids and that type of shit you need a couple of years
do at the end of the day.
But you have drink if you drink,
you know,
find some good wine,
you won't get a hangover.
I like a Barolo.
My uh,
my girls a big wine wine connoisseur and she knows she was buying like 15
bottle,
$20 bottles.
And I was getting headaches that go the fucking up at the 40 a bottle and then
it's fine.
You don't get headaches at all,
so it's not,
it doesn't have to be a hundred dollar bottle,
but yeah,
no wines of wines.
Good.
Now I love it.
I'm like,
this is fucking great.
It's nice and mellow and chill.
Yeah.
Would a meal and I get a little buzz man or it's like I get a little buzz on
like a glass and a half.
I'm like,
this is fucking awesome.
He said,
take me like 15 beers and now you know what's weird?
I'm drinking,
I'm drinking fag beers now.
I call him all the micro brews and stuff and I was never in the night.
I was like,
fucking,
what are you drinking it?
What the fuck?
Hell,
it tastes like.
Just give me a fucking core is light.
Give me a bud,
stop with this shit.
And My,
my,
my girl and her whole family drinks,
all those.
And I used to make fun.
I'm like the fucking Fag Beers,
right?
How can I,
can I want to,
core is light.
I want a bud light.
I'm not drunk.
I fucking fag beer.
Right.
I don't want to wheat ale summer fuck you.
And now that's all I drink.
Is that right?
Yeah.
I go to the micro brews just because I feel like I'm sticking it to the man.
But then I'm like,
who is the man?
The guy who makes Budweiser.
I love that guy.
Like I'm actually upset that cores light for the first time ever outsold
Budweiser.
So technically Budweiser isn't the king of American beers right now.
So I've been ordering more Budweiser trying to help them get up and over the bar
lately.
You know what I mean?
But I'm telling you retain their title,
those micro brews and all like oh this shit.
Those were the ales and stuff.
They don't give you a if,
I mean if you have eight or 10 yeah cause it's more pure.
And I never bought that shit.
I'm like whatever.
And I'm like,
I'm telling you just,
you know,
it's just better for you.
I got the hang of it just came from fucking,
you know,
you get to hydrate it with all the,
well that could too,
but know especially the light beers,
that they weren't something to it to make it light.
It's not fucking natural.
This is such a classic fucking like Bar Room.
Like none of us know.
We don't know what the fuck was that?
We don't know.
It's like the alcohol takes out a,
you know,
you had a light process.
You fucking drank this some guy who just creaming on me.
What the fuck you getting a light for?
You know what's the hardest thing when you're dry to watch as those fucking Sam
Adams commercials like they,
they have to be responsible for so many people losing their sobriety when they
sit there and they fucking snort and the hops like Goddamn Tony Montana,
they got one recently.
The guy literally jumps into the beer,
he's like swimming in beer and like when you're not,
like,
when I'm drinking,
I don't even notice those commercials.
But when I'm not drinking and I fucking see that,
like I actually get angry at the people at Sam Adams,
like [inaudible],
like,
I don't know who came up with that,
but they're making it so fucking appealing.
Right.
That A,
I dunno,
it th they,
they,
they annoy the shit on me,
but we're,
we're running out of time here.
We only got like a,
I mean,
I guess I can go as long as I want,
but I don't want to fucking,
uh,
I go by the,
the old showbiz adage of leaving them wanting more.
But that's why my podcast like 18 minutes,
22 and I love your podcast.
Oh,
me and Paul Versey Paul verse,
he's get does a great,
he does a great Florentine telling you it's,
it's,
uh,
he got me,
he's wanting to told me that you would do it because I didn't know you were
doing it.
And he's like,
dude,
he's like,
you gotta listen to Florentines puck.
Oh,
by the way,
hypey podcasts.
What,
where can people get it on iTunes?
Just comedy metal midgets.
It's called Jim Florentine comedy metal.
How many?
Yeah.
It's on my website,
Jim florentine.com I'm trying to think of how he does the impressions.
What are you kidding me?
Garbage.
Didn't yell.
Fuck,
fuck.
Oh yeah.
I know.
Some guy tweeted me a day.
He goes,
dude,
you sound so miserable when you start your podcast off.
I'm like,
yeah,
I am.
I'm fucking,
yeah,
I'm fucking sitting in my office by myself and something fucking bothers me.
I go,
I'm going to do a podcast about it.
I'm fucking,
I'm,
yeah,
I'm angry.
How do you think,
I know you're a big Miami dolphins fan from no one year.
All these years,
years.
How do you think they're going to be?
It could be pretty good.
You know what?
I got new coaches and Nigga fucking old man parcels out of there.
What?
It's fucking ancient,
1980s let's get some big bodies on the defensive offensive line.
Just stuff to run the,
and meanwhile it's been a passing league for the last 15 years.
You fat ass hole,
so thank God he's gone.
I fucking over write a piece of shit and you know they got a new guy in there.
He used to run the green bay on offense and they got that Tannehill got a rookie
quarterback and they got a couple of veterans.
So I'm psyched.
We'll see.
I mean they make our tenants six,
nine,
seven probably.
But you know,
new England's a fucking monster always going to be.
Yeah,
we check and Brady man.
we got lucky going to the Superbowl and you pay,
uh,
Peyton was out and when the Ravens beat us,
they just fucking choked.
Yeah,
absolutely.
No,
I paint and the Patriots and Miami's division,
I got no problem with them cause that's a well coached team and it just fucking,
they go for the kill.
They don't sit on leads when they're up.
27,
three is still throwing bombs.
I love that.
Well,
I know what you're going through as a fan because,
uh,
I had to deal with fucking Dan Marino.
Like I just was,
he just was unbelievable to me.
That guy is the best quarterback I've like,
he's,
he's the guy that I saw go from the college to the pro level and make it look
effortless.
Peyton Manning's a close second.
Yeah.
But,
um,
you know,
everybody see all these guys fucking breaking Dan Marino's records now it's
because of all the rules changes that they have.
Marina,
I always joked that marina would throw for 5,500,
6,000 yards until he had nobody,
he had no running game.
One of the,
one of the things that,
that,
uh,
I always talk about on this podcast is the fact that people give him shit that,
you know,
he didn't win a Superbowl and it's like the guy had no fucking defense.
You guys had like two white quarterbacks at one point.
Oh yeah.
We had the blackwood brothers [inaudible] yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The Brood.
Yeah.
There was like nine white guys on defense and two black coach and Berg.
Doug batters and Alicia,
you know what it,
Marino was telling me a story because I became friends and it was,
I worked on inside the NFL with them and he's Mike,
my ultimate idol.
He's the fucking greatest dude ever.
Marino.
He was Tom.
Dan does coordinator,
defense coordinator,
Tom Oliver Doddy who was the biggest piece of shit and he'd fucking rush three
old white guys.
And they would just keep,
that's why Ken O'Brien was a fucking genius against the g against my only
against Miami.
The guy was unbelievable.
He'd rushed three old white guys and they just leave another guy in the blood.
So it was six against story.
The quarterback had a mill,
you know all the time the world's,
so anyway,
he said before to San Francisco of dolphin,
a super ball,
a 49 has dolphins,
all of a Dadi to in the team meeting did a deep for the defense.
Saturday night before the Superbowl told him,
look,
I don't know what we,
we can't stop this team.
I don't know what to tell Ya.
I ain't got no plan.
And Marino heard that.
He goes,
dude,
he goes,
just stuck on the side.
It goes lie to them.
He goes,
fucking lied to him and just say we could.
We went down a plan because I would do it to my offensive line all the time.
Coming back and out of it.
You can block Bruce Smith.
No,
I can't.
You can.
He's a fucking pussy.
You can block them.
Just fucking get him on his knees.
It,
cause I knew we couldn't,
but I gave the guy encouragement.
He goes,
well,
no exam,
Marino head,
he had no running back.
See like Delvin Williams,
Tony,
Nathan,
Kareem Abdul,
Sammy Smith,
he had nobody,
he had one guide.
Grimaldi Jabar gained 1200 yards one season.
He only had one running back rush for a thousand yards and a 17 year career.
Right.
And then he also had,
he had Don Shula who the game had passed them by.
Um,
and then who do you have?
Jimmy John's,
Jimmy Johnson.
Jimmy Johnson seemed like he wanted him out the door the second he got to the
Johnson hated them.
Right.
Mario told me a great story real quick.
You said,
um,
that's,
you know,
we're going to go along.
If he hated fucking know.
Damn Marina,
we're going to hate Jimmy Johnson.
Jimmy Johnson was a dick to them and it's a they,
there was no reason for it.
He goes,
I bought into his plan,
but he,
so anyway,
he said that one time he goes,
you know,
coach Shula Schuler was a coach.
He goes,
I'll tell you.
Shula had a dog named Zamka.
How fucking bulldog names Onca.
That's a fucking coach.
He goes,
Jimmy Johnson and a little fucking Yorkie that he would bring on the,
on the team planes.
He goes,
well,
we're trying to play buffalo in the championship game.
And he's in,
he's in the first seat in a fucking plane.
Petten fluffy goes,
how am I going to fucking win when a coach that brings a fucking six pound
Yorkie named fluffy and he's fucking got on his lap fucking pet the thing when
coach Shula has got Sonka,
that's a coach.
The d ever talk about getting annoyed with people talking about him not winning
a super bowl.
I'm not really,
he just said,
look,
you know what?
It's a team game.
What am I going to do?
You know,
you try and that's all he could do.
But he,
oh,
he,
he said,
everyone brings up the fake spike play.
He goes,
you know,
cause he works out of New York on CBS.
He's always in New York and he's like,
all these jet fans called get den.
You know,
I hated you back then,
but I do like,
but that fake spike,
you killed us,
you know,
and he says,
he goes,
I just tell him,
get over it.
Just get over it already.
All right.
It was fricking 1991
get all he did that.
What did that do to them then?
Knock them out and they weren't.
They were eight and five at the time.
The judge that we're going there,
we're on a roll.
They won like six straight and Marino did the fake spike and they didn't win
another game the rest of the year.
They went eight and eight and then they went one and 15 and actually they went
to and 32 after that game.
What is with fucking New York and Boston?
I don't know if anybody else does it.
They're always into like the,
the,
that old lady curse jinx.
Like you didn't win another fucking game after that cause you sucked.
That's a load.
That's why,
because you didn't fucking,
you weren't ready to play.
Not because he liked that whole curse of the babe horseshit.
It completely ignores that.
The ownership of the red sox were like,
you know,
they could have started the clan with some of their fucking ideas and like the
whole game changed once Jackie Robinson went in and they completely fucking
ignored it.
And then also let's say that even if they weren't racist,
like what the Yankees did going from,
you know,
I mean they got Babe Ruth,
uh,
they bought him,
but they got Lou Gehrig to Joe Dimaggio to Mickey Mantle.
That's like,
it's like going Jordan to Jordan to Jordan.
One fucking franchise did that and that was the real deal back then when you
went to spot talent and they came up through your system and it's just like,
you never going to see that again.
Like,
especially now,
like I'm,
I'm not a big fan of these,
like these pile on teams.
I thought it was really weird that Miami got like the shit that they did and
it's like,
why doesn't anybody shit on the Lakers?
Like they do just basically every fucking year with what my team,
the Celtics did in 2008 we thought that title.
Yeah.
You know,
but the Lakers do it every fucking year and,
and,
and they're like,
Colby,
he's got five championships.
One more,
uh,
you know,
we equals Jordan.
It's like,
dude,
Jordan had Luc Longley and fucking my listeners like bill,
we've heard this is the only time go fuck yourself.
I don't give a shit.
Luc Longley and Fucking,
uh,
Bill Cartwright,
its center.
And the only,
the only big guy that I remember them signing was fucking Dennis Rodman.
Yeah.
Robin they got from Detroit and they had him during his last three productive
fucking years.
But like a Scottie Pippin,
that was the,
his guy with the head blonde hair dude and Bj fucking Armstrong me break.
Yeah.
Well you're right.
Absolutely.
They,
um,
but also in respect for my listeners,
my hatred of the Lakers is so fucking blinding that it really kills any sort of
rational thoughts.
Having said that,
I love Colby.
I love his mentality.
I loved when he doesn't win a championship and he doesn't just go water skiing
right after he loses,
he fucking goes right into the front office and is like,
what the fuck?
Yeah.
Get me some guys like that.
I wish everybody would do that.
No,
absolutely.
I hate when they fucking smile after I just lost a game on and they start
hugging it out and they started hugging and shit like that.
Say,
hey,
how's it going at you at the last second and a fucking field goal of 47 yarder
and then you're smiling and two seconds later,
patting them on the head.
We do.
We do that as comics.
If we a bad set and fucking fuck.
Yeah,
let's go.
I'm a fuck.
Yeah.
I'm going to want to sell cds.
Hey,
what's,
that was fucking great.
It's fucking saying it back a miserable.
Absolutely not.
Well,
let me ask you this last thing I got to have you on again though,
I would love to.
Every guest could be as effortless.
I'm telling you.
I appreciate you and dom,
I rare was another one just fucking sat down here.
We just,
we came into the house,
shot the shit upstairs,
came down here and turn on the Mike shot the shit,
turned it off,
walked upstairs.
It just was seamless.
Um,
but I was gonna ask you like this new thing that hopefully it's just a fucking
little blip.
I actually get always refills old to talk about is this new thing where people
will film a comedian at a fucking comedy club and then you put it up and you
have to apologize for a fucking joke.
Is that the most insane fucking thing?
It's,
fuck,
it's,
it's brutal.
It is just fucking the biggest,
biggest bunch of fucking pussies.
Well,
you know I love is every joke that they've done it,
the crowd in the club is laughing.
Yeah.
And then they go,
it sparked outrage.
It's like where,
yeah,
it,
the title tailors their fucking little fucking,
I'm going to tell you did I said,
I was saying,
I go basically that come into our work and filming us at a moment that they
think we're doing something wrong and they've given it to the boss,
which is our audience or the public and going,
hey,
do something about this.
Look what they did.
That's like magic.
I said,
imagine if we go into someone's work tomorrow and the Guy Smoking Pot at fucking
lunchtime or he's looking at porn.
There's computer when he's supposed to doing his fucking pay,
whatever right.
Doing is fucking spreadsheet.
And we go and we filmed my girl boss,
look,
he was looking at porn.
Look,
what are you going to do about it?
But even then,
I don't think that's a fair comparison because trying out new material is,
is not smoking weed at work.
He's,
you're doing what you supposed to be doing.
Know some of the best bits come out of of doing something edgy and there is a
style,
this shock comedy,
there's dark comedy.
That is all that type of stuff in feud is fucking sit there and act like you
hired this guy to,
to to look at.
People aren't here at my fucking opinion.
So let me,
I'm sorry.
I said,
imagine if Redd Foxx and you know it's San Fran and Sundays he was a filthy
comic.
I mean disgusting on stage.
Imagine what people were feeling were recording him and going listen to this.
He wouldn't had a show,
a show or whatever off the air.
I know he's talking about eating some girl's asshole,
you know,
and when no one talked about that in the fucking early seventies,
I don't think people care about it.
It would be if he said something about the president or if he says it like this.
Um,
like that toll Dane Cook joke.
He was basically letting people know that this addition of Batman isn't as good
as the other one.
That's the way I looked at it.
That's what I got out of it.
Yeah.
He just said it's a shitty movie.
And then people get out.
Yeah.
He's advocating.
He isn't,
he isn't such,
it just,
I just stay out of the clubs,
you know,
the wrestling,
the WWE had to apologize.
So what did it,
cause they made a joke about what it was such a fucking great joke.
This manager is,
is talking shit to the crowd about the wrestler that he's,
and he's going,
you know,
so and so would have the guy's name is,
he goes,
he's like Colby Bryant in a Colorado Hotel Room.
Unstoppable.
Right.
It was,
and he delivered a big,
it's funny.
Yeah.
And he not only did you have to apologize,
he had to apologize to somebody,
a specific person who wasn't Colby or the girl.
Right.
I was Mike something or other,
I remember,
you know,
reading and passing,
but it's like,
it's getting to the point of like,
it's sort of a,
I like,
uh,
it's ridiculous,
but I,
I look at it like it's kind of scares me because it seems like,
uh,
if,
if allowed,
it's the beginning of like,
you're going to like start censoring people.
They,
they say in the beginning don't film the comedians.
And that's another thing too.
None of these comics uploaded that shit to try to,
uh,
reach anybody else other than,
yeah.
Who the fuck they were performing too,
you know?
Absolutely.
And you know what I mean?
Someone made a good point.
My friend was saying,
he goes,
you know what I mean?
Basically what they're doing is they're,
it's illegal.
There are illegally recording you,
right.
You have to,
in most states,
you have to have permission to record somebody.
So we're basically doing is,
is doing is illegal by secretly tape recording us.
Right.
You know,
comedy clubs need to,
what they have to do is they have to fucking leave everybody's phones and cell
phones at the fucking,
at the bar before they walk in the room.
Oh,
they're not going to do that.
They're not going to that because they want to turn over the crowd quicker.
They don't give a fuck.
I know it's too bad.
Someone that you considered considered as art should do that.
Go Look,
you leave in your fucking phones and I'd record is put them here.
I put them in.
What I do notice though,
the only people that they ask to apologize,
there are people who have like hit TV shows.
You know what I mean?
True.
Absolutely.
So I think,
uh,
I think I'm safe.
I don't know about you.
You don't have to know.
It's VH one classic.
It's like a basic cable.
It's only checked the NFL network.
We're only at 40% of homes doing it.
You know what I actually think.
I think that they way that into into consideration those groups where they sit
there and they go,
okay,
how big is Jim Florentine?
How big is bill?
How big about this guy?
This guy has got like,
you know,
whatever,
like what memo on Corolla made fun or like transgender people or whatever.
He goes,
I don't know what the hell are you are?
Whatever his joke was,
he did it on his podcast and they tried to go after him and they go,
what are they going to take away his podcast?
It's his own podcast,
right?
He's got like dotcoms you know,
like fucking advertised or whatever.
Then I can,
he said he doesn't have any and so he didn't apologize.
No he didn't Apollo cause they couldn't do anything.
That's perfect.
He's got his own network.
What is it going?
What are they going to do?
They try perfect.
He didn't say one word.
Fuck Yo.
That's perfect.
I know.
So yeah,
that's how I look at it.
See that's,
that's my thing.
Why,
why,
why do you want to go to the next level where all of a sudden you have to start
apologizing for trying out material?
You know,
I get it.
This is the deal.
If I was sick of doing the road,
I would,
I would be a more apt to want to go that other route.
But like,
I dunno,
I dunno.
This is this,
this is supposed to be about you.
I'm sitting here fun,
psycho analyze comics.
No,
I hate it.
It's,
it's the worst thing that can happen.
The comedy.
Yeah,
it's the worst.
It would be long.
I want to take chances.
Well,
I just look at it,
look,
if they,
they,
there is the style of comedy that those people who get offended are looking for
exists out there.
Okay.
You didn't go to that show.
You know,
you didn't have to click on it.
You didn't have to listen to it.
You chose to listen to the fucking thing.
And the guy who said it didn't choose to film an upload it.
Somebody else did.
So,
I don't know.
I'm talking in circles here.
My mom is 74 years old.
She's super religious.
She's just watches like touched by an angel all day.
She found the tool,
my shows in 20 years when the two of my comedy shows,
right.
So I wanted a vital like six months ago,
mom come to me,
she goes,
no,
I don't like the words that come out of your mouth.
You're going to make me uncomfortable.
I go,
look,
I'm going to be cleaned tonight cause I was working on the clean set.
Right.
And you know what she said?
She goes,
yeah,
but I don't know about the other acts on the show.
I don't know what they're going to say.
So I'm going to stay home.
That's how does a 74 year old woman get it?
But nobody else does.
I don't know what the other racks are gonna say,
so I'm going to stay home.
It makes that choice.
She didn't want to go into that situation had she gone down there,
she knows what she's getting herself into.
Exactly.
Done.
She goes,
well I made that choice to go down there even though my son was in,
but I went to a show.
How does she get it right.
Does that bother you that she's only come out twice?
No,
not at all.
Cause I could feel uncomfortable.
What are in the audience?
I said this on TV one time I did George Lopez Jari did stand up on it.
I said Penis and my act and she's like,
oh,
I can't believe you embarrass the family.
You have nieces.
What?
They sought out.
What do you I go mom,
if I start thinking about my fucking 10 year old niece when I'm writing jokes,
my career's over now how did you with with the mom is religious?
Is that we do.
Did you rebel against it?
Of Brutal.
It was brutal.
Yeah.
Pro.
How bad did she make you a dress and like sue on tied it all in the boy,
all that stuff and you know,
sign me up for die Catholic schools my whole life,
you know,
put in,
I'm from,
Oh my God.
Oh yeah.
From you know,
kindergarten base.
Now what point will you,
uh,
deciding that this wasn't the road for you,
was it what the priests were saying or like what,
why?
Probably have after like the third group,
cause all my friends were in public school and I wanted to hang out with them.
I was hanging it and you know,
I just hated it right off the bat and they were like,
no,
it was a better education on the cow.
How is it?
I got fucking priest teaching me math.
He doesn't know about fucking math.
A non is teaching me fucking English,
you know?
Yeah.
That's a better education.
Right.
You know,
even in high school,
my fucking,
you went all the way through till senior year house through senior year.
Wow.
Yeah.
I got thrown out of the two schools.
Two schools for being out of control.
And what was that?
What was it was out of control.
Why they had these,
they were bragging,
you know what,
I make the announcements in the morning.
Oh you know what?
Whatever.
You know,
so you have to say a prayer and all that shit.
So they said,
oh we just bought these wrestling maps who spent a lot of money on it for a gym
class.
So please take care of them.
So fuckings my next gym class later that day I fucking caught him out where
razor,
it was like fucking $3,000 worth of wrestling match.
And I cut the fucking stage curtains to why?
I don't know.
Just cause they said take care of them.
I don't really take care of them.
Be,
you know.
Okay fine.
I'm going to cut them up with razor blades.
And how did you get caught?
Well they didn't know it was made.
They knew it was from us,
from our class,
cause we were like the last class of a day,
like eighth period or whatever.
So they knew it was somebody in our class and it was only me and two other
fucking derelicts and a class.
So they narrowed it down to us three and they had us in the office every day.
We know you did it.
They'd punch me in the face,
smack me,
pull my hair,
stare at the wall.
We get hours.
Yeah.
And I'm like,
okay,
fine.
I would stare at the wall.
I wouldn't admit it.
I had a fucking swear on a Bible.
My mom took me to a,
our local priest and she goes,
I want you to swear on a Bible.
You didn't do this.
And I swear on a Bible,
ugh.
And I didn't do it.
Yeah.
Which is hilarious if you don't believe in this shit.
I'm like,
yeah,
I'll do that.
I'll fucking be up.
Put me,
give you a whole stack of yeah,
whatever book.
Yeah.
I don't give a shit.
What puts lashes?
Look,
I'll swear on that toe.
So did you start partying and that stuff?
Uh,
he started getting into the weed and drinking probably like 14 or 15 I was good
in sports.
Like baseball was on the freshman team.
I was playing on the soccer.
I played on the Varsity team as a freshman.
But then like sophomore year I started getting into their frigging varsity as a
freshman.
I was a lefty pitcher.
I was really good.
At some point I was a good hit or two I played first base,
but then I just started drinking and getting into smoking pot and cigarettes my
sophomore year.
And that was it.
So did you,
did your mom,
did she and my dad was pissed.
Did your mom know you were doing any of that stuff?
Not really.
Cause I had older brothers.
They would kind of like,
you know that that's why I started getting really metal.
They'll bring them to concerts at 14 I saw fucking ACDC.
What?
Bon Scott.
That's another 12 year old kid.
You asset the powerage tour?
No,
it was a,
it was highway to hell.
Jesus Christ on mom for Ted Nugent at Madison Square Garden.
And I saw him a,
an ACDC and I forget who else.
I think it was def Leppard.
Maybe it what bond like two times before he died because my brothers would bring
me,
I was 12 and they were like 18 and like all we want to bring up.
So I saw all these shows.
Holy Shit.
Sane.
So you would go from Catholic school to then going down to one of those goddamn
shows at 12 yeah.
Partying with your older brothers.
Yeah.
They would like get me high.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Dude,
you had a fucking awesome childhood now.
It was great.
I mean,
I was angry because I was fucking stuck in Catholic school and shit like that.
But yeah.
Uh,
but no,
it was absolutely man.
But all the brothers would bring home my albums,
like all the pillows of this black sabbath and his Ted Nugent,
Aerosmith and my colleague just fucking great.
That's awesome.
My younger brother's got that out of me.
I was second oldest,
so they,
uh,
you know,
I didn't know shit.
Like my first album was a Mitch Miller Sing along with Mitch and the gang.
Okay.
Or shouldn't even know who they are.
They line,
I know.
Yeah,
they're like Polka.
Yeah.
Won't you come Home Bill Bailey?
Like that type of shit.
And then I got Aerosmith's greatest hits was my first foray into like fucking
real music,
but my first concert was a Er doc and Judas priest.
Nice.
No.
Oh yeah,
no,
it was,
yeah,
that's right.
I was,
I thought it was a loudness.
It was dark.
And Judas Priest loudness opened up for ACDC on the who made who tour that
Japanese heavy metal band.
Um,
there's still around.
Are they really?
Yeah,
we were going to have the guitar player play on our show,
but he had a cane.
He couldn't get a,
because you've gone out to go see any,
any of a band's from like the that aren't like huge,
like the Metallica as the ACDC set are still playing arenas.
Like I'll go out to Vegas every once in a while doing a gig out there and I'll
see like slaughters playing with like fucking warrant a couple other guys.
Have you gone out to any of those shows?
I just saw Sebastian Bach last night at and,
okay.
Yeah.
Oh you did?
Oh yeah,
I is.
How was it?
It was great man.
He still can sing.
He's got a good band behind them and stuff.
So yeah,
I always go see shows.
Now is he going to get together?
Uh,
with skid row?
He wants to,
does one guy in a band that doesn't want to do it?
The only other guy who can remember rob a few.
So was drama.
Drama.
Yeah.
Rachel in is to basically make something or like say about guitar player.
So who doesn't want to do it?
I think Rachel,
a bass player,
he,
he hates a bash and so much that he won't do it and they got offers like 100
grand to do festivals overseas.
They could do so what,
what kind of money does that do to have Rachel?
I don't know.
I guess he gets to publish it on those first couple of records.
You know youth gone wild.
I remember you every time I think that that would be trickling down.
Now the kids are just down like it is just sports stadiums and shit like that.
I guess he's got money coming in.
We were watching me and my buddy out he last night,
every time she bad cause Sebastian film the first TV show last night or
something.
So every time we played a skid row songs I got Rachel can buy another house
because he has to pay for that.
It goes to him anytime.
Sebastian does anything on TV or put a DVD out of those songs is Sebastian write
those songs.
So Rachel did Rachel on snake road?
His name is Rachel.
Yeah,
I know.
Why is it Rachel?
I don't know.
Rachel Bolan.
I'm not sure from Europe or something.
Now he's jersey,
jersey,
white trash,
like May.
All right.
What do we got here?
We're an hour and 20 minutes in and it just keeps getting more interesting.
We got to do a part two at some point.
I'm in La.
Yeah.
When are you going to come out?
I come out back out in October.
I'll be back out.
I was thinking the last time I think I saw you in La.
I ran into you at the forum for that ACDC concert.
Remember one of the greatest shows I've ever seen in my life.
Yeah,
we caught it early in frightens fucking voice.
Sounded Gray.
Fucking killer.
All right,
well let's wrap it up here.
Jim Florentine.
Your website is [inaudible] dot com on Twitter and Mister Jim Florentine and uh,
my podcast,
comedy metal midgets on iTunes and when can we see the next additions of a
season?
That metal shell starts?
August 11th on VH one classic.
One classic.
Yeah.
Okay.
August 11th it's coming up.
All right,
Jim,
thank you so much for coming by the podcast.
Thanks bill.
All right.
amazon.com you guys know the deal.
If you're going to buy something on Amazon,
not saying you gotta go to Bill bird.com.
Click on the podcast page and click on the banner ad on the right hand side,
the Amazon banner ad on the right hand side.
You go to Amazon,
go ahead and buy something.
It doesn't cost you any extra money.
They kicked me a percentage.
10% of that I give to the wounded warriors project.
He helped support my podcast and a the troops who made an unbelievable sacrifice
for us.
All right.
And gameplay Dotcom.
What'd you love to have?
8,000 get video games at your fingertips,
Cheryl.
We,
oh,
what?
Um,
all the new hits mailed to your home.
So if you're sick of paying $65 for the newest games that you or your kids use
for a week and then give,
then give game flyers,
shot game flyers offering my listeners a free to discuss 15 day trial,
$23 value.
Go to www.game fly.com or the game fly banner on the,
on my podcast page of the website to redeem the offer.
There you go.